so yeah this one's not gonna be quite as
joyous so as I mentioned in my video
sort of looking back over 2018
I believe I have chosen to address
looking forward into 2019 in a separate
video because it's gonna be a little
less sort of AA first thing they make
clear right off the bat I'm not stopping
doing this I'm not going away nothing
physically wrong with me or any loved
ones I'm not moving like I'm not there's
nothing like that going on but I'm just
sort of I'm dealing with a handful of
things that make me worried about the
future of this channel so the the main
sort of thing that I'm talking about
here it's sort of links to my job which
is something that I don't really talk
about I'm not gonna go into a ton of
details on here but so things that my
job are sort of shifting around a bit in
a way that is likely going to have an
impact on my financial stability and in
addition to that is gonna require not
more time like it's not like I have to
put in overtime or anything like that
but has a likelihood to demand more of
my energy any given day and that makes
me worried about being able to maintain
the output I have been and in doing
daily videos cuz again while I'm not
losing time I do worry about having the
energy to keep the pace that I have been
which so far has not caused me burnout
but I'm a little worried looking into
next year because the thing is like I
love
I absolutely love doing this but this
doesn't pay my bills my job does so if
I'm in a situation where I cannot
perform at the level that I would like
to in one or the other and I have to
pick and choose I have no choice but to
pick my job now I I feel really bad
about doing this but I would feel worse
if I didn't which is I've tried very
hard not to ever come across as pleading
when it comes to the patreon and
supporting this and me and what I do I'm
actually insanely grateful and I
consider the patron to be by my
standards a rousing success and like I'm
in a position right now where I was kind
of looking at you know about two maybe
two and a half years down the line I
assume assuming some things that I can
control and some things that I can't
lining up properly like I could have
possibly seen that that doing this
between the patreon and the growth on
the subscriber base might be able to be
my primary source of income in about two
two and a half years that you know again
that's assuming a few things that I can
control like YouTube doesn't implode
completely change its payout structure
or the algorithm doesn't screw me over
but it that also kind of presumed steady
growth and while it's hard to know how
much of an impact it has on the growth I
have no doubt that the fact that I've
had daily output for most of 2018 is a
contributing factor to the pace of
growth and if I ever have to dial that
back that could very well stall the
channel so coming back to the patreon
like I said I've worked very hard not to
not to plead people I don't like to feel
like I'm holding the show in this
channel to ransom and I'm trying very
hard to not come across like I'm doing
that now some people might still
interpret it that way
I can say as I'm sorry but here's the
here's the fiscal reality if 10% of my
subscriber base support of the patreon
at a $2 level $2 month level this would
be my job like this would be it
if 10% supported at a $1 level this may
not be able to be able to be the only or
like the the thing that I do has a
full-time but it might free me up to to
find you know part-time work that would
be a supplement an income supplement as
opposed to having to do a 40-hour a week
and here's the thing I know enough about
patreon size and growth versus channel
size and growth to know that either one
of those is not realistic but like I
said I would feel as much as I don't I'm
not enjoying making this video I would
feel worse if I sort of bottled all this
up and then ultimately had to make the
call to dial back on my content output
and did that without ever having taken a
shot without ever having reached out and
tried and I mean I don't know what the
outcome of this will be you know but
I've been by this I mean this video but
you know the phrase every little bit
helps is trite and it's kind of a stock
saying that anyone who is
crowdfunded tends to throw out there but
honestly it's true a dollar a month from
enough people
supports a career so and I think another
part of the reason I'm gonna plug I'm
gonna do this as a video is that I don't
want to plug the patreon any harder in
my regular video output video output
than I already do and sort of I get I
guess I'm kind of pouring it into this
one video so that I won't have to feel
the need to spread it out across a whole
bunch of other videos and maybe I'll be
ok anyways like maybe as I as I get a
sense of the rejiggering of how what's
going on with my job is affecting my
finances and I'll land and I'll be ok
and they'd be sort of extra drain won't
be so much that it disrupts the channel
maybe it all work out and it'll all be
fine but I'm not the kind of person to
kind of stick my fingers in my ears and
go lalalalala a lot hope that that's the
way it turns out so I'm really sorry
everybody to like throw a downer one in
here especially like year end and coming
off a really phenomenal year as far as
all this goes 2018 was incredible but
like just the way my brain works I tend
to look what's the future look at look
like for the trajectory that I'm on and
where things are lining up and the 2018
was almost like the perfect trajectory
for things that trajectory outlook has
changed
going into 2019 and maybe it'll get
realigned again into a better place but
where it is right now it's it's
potentially gonna be a really tough year
so sorry to put it on a down note guys
but I mean look the patreon links down
below any amount helps it really really
really does and there are rewards there
are things you get even at the one
dollar level you
you get to vote on like which big finish
or classic Doctor Who episode I'm gonna
I'm gonna do you know the following
month and you get to see the docket when
I put it up at the start of the month of
what my plan is to cover that that month
on a daily basis and you know two-dollar
level gets you on the discord and then
up from there there's other things there
are rewards and all that but I don't I
don't want to like go through and plug
all those on an individual basis you can
read them if you want to go to the
patreon it just anything does help from
enough people little drops will fill the
jar we'll see what happens I hope
everyone has a great new year
sorry if I brought it down for you a
little bit damn
but whatever you want to share about
this you know call me a shell if you
feel you must
but whatever whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it a whole bunch of
stuff you can do such as click the
buttons in the links including the one
to the patreon but even after all I've
said even if you don't want to do that
it's okay because at the end of the day
you guys are the council I just from the
meetings and I want to keep having these
meetings for as often in as long as I
can manage until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]